hallo leute wir starten heute die
trainingswoche 5 das heißt fit aus dem
lockt dann in der fünften woche heute
ein intensives rumpfprogramm mit niki
mit dem herbert mit mir den peter wir
starten los am besten gleich mit
aufwärmen mit lockerem laufen am stand
geht schloss auch hier beim rumpf
krafttraining wenn es körperlich
intensiv wird müssen wir natürlich ein
bisserl intensiver aufwärmen
das heißt bei fahren zwar locker aber
wir werden das ganze dann entsprechend
steigern wenn wir wieder wie gewohnt am
kreisen mit dazu hände vorwärts kreisen
und rückwärts kreisen
und gleich gegen gleich noch dazu
richtung wechseln richtung wechseln
einmal auch richtung wechseln und kurz
ausläuft kann
wir gehen weiter sprunggelenk kreisen
einstand in der drehung richtung
wechseln seite wechseln und wieder
richtung wechseln
ein abstellen lockerer boxer love auch
im bocksaal auf kann man natürlich
variieren was die beine machen das heißt
man kann einmal diese breiter stehen man
kann ein bisschen länger stehen man kann
unterschiedliche schritt positionen
wählen und trotzdem weiterlaufen
genau
wir bleiben widerstehen hände auf die
kniescheiben lockeres kreis und aus dem
kniegelenk richtung wechseln
wir setzen uns auf die matte kurze
grätsche und kippen die zehenspitzen
nach innen und nach außen gegen gleich
oder eine seite ganz egal an winkeln der
beine und knie hin und her links und
rechts zum boden bewegen
da kann man die hüfte natürlich auch
wieder hinein und in den unteren rücken
wenn man schon auf der matte und ums
andre mal uns gleich um vier füße stand
wobei die knie am boden bleiben und
macht man ganz an runden rücken und
wechseln in den geraden beziehungsweise
in den gebogenen in dem pferderücken
also katzenbuckel pferderücken im
wechsel zwei drei mal hin und her
wechseln
stehen wir wieder auf bewegen wir uns
wieder kampelmann springen auf wechsel
in den lang schritt beziehungsweise die
hände auch nach vor wechseln wechsel
wieder zurück in den hampelmann wechsel
nach vor und zurück wechseln den
hampelmann aus locker ausschlafen kurz
damit luftholen oberkörper verdrehen
linke hand rechte hand hin und her
kreisen der schwungmasse rück mitnehmen
dann drehen wir das becken kleine kreise
kleine becken kreise richtung wechseln
wechsel man indirekte man auch mal die
richtung und manchmal größere kreise das
heißt das ganze becken dreht sich
schauen wir dass man den kopf möglichst
stabil halten aber der rest rund herum
darf sich durch drehen das durch bewegt
werden richtung wechseln album seitlich
hochdrehen im ellbogen richtung wechseln
richtung wechseln
gleich die handgelenke dazunehmen
handgelenk kreisen es zusammengreifen
dynamische bewegung richtung wechseln
richtung wechseln
wir gehen runter in die logische
ausgangsstellung martin klein bei 20
sekunden dynamisch des cellos achten
darauf stolzer brust gerade rücken kopf
in verlängerung der wirbelsäule und
dynamisch das knie oder beide knie dann
im wechsel nach vor zu meldung zur post
in fünf sekunden und das aufstehen
ausloggen durchschlafen wieder
wir machen oberkörper vertreten in der
vorbeuge es ist einmal körper vor candy
dazu links und rechts zum boden zu den
zehenspitzen zum knie je nachdem wie
weit herunter kommt hinunter drehen
wir wechseln wieder in den stadtlauf
ganz kurz staat bedeutet schnell laufen
stopp bedeutet langsam laufen start stop
& start
stock statt
rohstoff und wieder kurz aus locker mal
fünf sprünge
das heißt nicht in die tiefe beuge aber
locker reingehen wegspringen ganz kurze
schnelle boden kontakte schnell hin und
her wechseln
der 4 und 5 aussagen heißt über seine
fans nach blick wendung links blick
wendung rechts hin und her wechseln und
nach oben schauen und nach unten bewegen
jetzt kannst du ja mal ausprobieren wenn
ihr nach oben schaut nach oben den kopf
bewegt und gleichzeitig nach unten
schaut ob das funktioniert probiert
einmal ja und dann wird es ganz
wesentlich konzentrierter und wir kippen
den kopf von der linken auf die rechte
seite und wir schauen nach links und
rollen über die brust auf die rechte
seite im wechsel hin und her
nehmen wir die eltern noch mal hoch mal
zweimal album zurückziehen und dreimal
viermal album tant aufspannen 1234 1234
jeder für sich 345 kurzausflug kann
einmal noch vorbei ist und wie man es
von den schwimmern gehabt haben die arme
nach vor und zurück schleudern
da ein die beweglichkeit schön
hineinarbeiten genau und auslagern
unser werk hat unser programm für heute
mit dem inhalt des rumpfs krafttrainings
wird beinhalten klarerweise vor dem
muskelkater seitliche und rückwärtige
muskelkater und das in
unterschiedlichsten übungen teilweise
welche die man schon gemacht haben die
bekannt sind und teilweise auch neue
übungen von zeit anhalten 30 sekunden
belasten 30 sekunden pause machen und
wie ist das bereits die die körperlich
richtig gas geben wohin arbeiten die
minute durch riskieren im blick und
schauen wie die nächste übung ausschaut
und machen einen fliegenden übungs
wechsel ok wird von sagen wir zeigen die
erste übung vor und zwar vier füße und
strecken arme und beine nicht da für die
bieten aber in den vierfüßlerstand ganz
wichtig gerade rücken stabil aus dem
oberkörper knies zwei zentimeter vom
boden weg und jetzt da linke hand
rechtes bein rechte hand linkes bein
total schwierig dort als sagt zum
ausgleichen aber wenig gemacht es
perfekt zeigt euch das super vor einfach
aber jetzt wenn die knie am boden sind
mir gibt es da mal vor knie am boden
beide hände
beide hände geht eine hand ein bein her
und wenn das ein bisschen zu schwer ist
nimmt nur das bein oder nur die hand
danke nur kurze pause in 20 sekunden
staatenlos vierfüßlerstand strecken arme
und beine richtig intensiv 30 belasten
der herbert macht auch eine minute durch
die nicht gemacht 30 sekunden und im
zweiten durchgang wechseln wir ihr kennt
das genauso machen
einen durchgangs flugzeug aus minute
durch arbeiten den zweiten oder den
ersten dann entsprechend mit der pause
bot los gehts 30 sekunden arbeitszeit ab
jetzt schön ausgleichen stehen stabil
bleiben das ist ganz ganz schwierige
übung
zwischendrin immer wieder auch das
gleichgewicht finden
sehen sie konnten nur nach 321 30
sekunden basel david halbzeit nächste
übung fersen das heißt aus der position
sieht ups das ist die startposition
lebte die beine hoch und berührt innen
ferse und phase bewegt dabei dass bei
nach vor und zurück gesetzt wie das
ausschauen soll
wem das zu schwierig ist fersen am boden
und trotzdem links und rechts innen
hineingreifen schöne schräglage mein
oberkörper nach hinten und dann passt es
in drei sekunden zwei einer arbeitszeit
30 sekunden jetzt genau bauchmuskulatur
unter voller spannung der hüftbeuge
arbeitet mit da haben wir große
körperliche belastung wie gesagt zweite
variante ist ein bisserl einfacher
schauen dass der schöne schräglage habt
aber über die rotation des oberkörpers
körpers wird es dann ziemlich
anstrengend spätestens wenn ihr die
minute durch arbeitet das ist das
stichwort in drei sekunden 21 pause und
die die fertig machen haben halbzeit
ok jetzt gehen wir in den rücken eine
rücknahme beziehungsweise schulterblatt
fix autoren übung das heißt einmal
ablegen den körper um 90 grad vom körper
weg und er drückt euch drückt die
ellbogen in den boden hinein sodass sich
der oberkörper loslöst ihr kennt euch
vielleicht erinnern feed am arbeitsplatz
noch mal dass an der mauer gemacht das
ist natürlich auch eine alternative
ich kann diese übung aber natürlich auch
am boden machen und ganz wichtig der
bauch bleibt entspannt auch übungen
werden sondern eine rücken bzw
schulterblatt fixateur einübung von
bachelors navigations wechsel die 1
ist es am bauch zu legen das sagt euch
daher rät vor das heißt in der bauchlage
sie die hände nach oben die ellbogen
bewegen sich nach oben und der 6 wir
kommen genau da in dem bereich
schulterblätter schulterblatt fix
autoren auch hinein ist sie zusammen es
geht auf sc zusammen es geht aus drei
sekunden noch nie geschafft
und sei es aus 30 sekunden schulterblatt
faktoren kann man schon wieder erledigt
nächsten übung den meister für die
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur beziehungs
und die ganze seitliche muskelkater in
den salzstock
das ist die ausgangsposition jetzt hebt
sie die hand greift und dem körper
soweit durch wie möglich und dreht
wieder nach oben eine dynamische
bewegung danke ständig so schaut es aus
etwas einfach haben jetzt mit kurzen
hebel
das heißt rechter winkel im bein und
station wechsel herbert zeit stützt und
jetzt auch hier achtet darauf der kopf
ist in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
darum wie es immer unter spannung da
hinten ist angespannt und so arbeiten
die rotation in die drehung ein
ihr habt es noch zehn sekunden 3 2 1
und kurze pause wir machen keine zweite
seite dazu das heißt einfach nur die
seite wechseln position finden in 20
sekunden geht schüler los ok achtet
wieder darauf eine ebene zu haben
zwischen der schulter und dem
sprunggelenk das heißt der popo bleibt
oben in fünf sekunden erkennt schon die
position einnehmen startposition 21
unserer webseite wechseln kopf bleibt in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule hintern ist
gespannt
die seitlichen bauchmuskulatur natürlich
auch sonst kann die position enthäuten
so bleibt auch das becken gestreckt dann
weiter atmen sie in sekunden noch 521 30
sekunden durch
also stützt muskulatur hammer linke und
rechte seite erledigt jetzt gehen wir in
eine liegestütz variante die haben wir
nicht gemacht wir sind in der fünften
woche ja möchte das festhalten an es
gibt noch immer liegestütz varianten die
man nicht macht dann obwohl man wirklich
für liegestütze absolviert haben das
kommt bestimmt nicht sagt einmal kurz
vor er habe du hast mal zehn sekunden
einfach ein bein hoch rechter winkel und
geht schon wir pumpen in drei sekunden
satz mit dabei 21 und wechsel auch hier
die einfache variante kann es gerne das
knie am boden ablegen das zweite und nur
ein bayern oben haben genau und bei
jedem liegestütz kennt sie das ohne
weiteres hin und her wechseln dann wird
es richtig anstrengend leichter blick
nach vorn nicht in den boden hinein
poren den kopf wenn es anstrengend wird
fünf sekunden
und 30 sekunden sind wieder durch
spürbar in den ärmel
ja genau also richtig anstrengend
richtig belasten
wir wechseln wieder in eine bauch übung
das heißt rückenlage der scheibenwischer
hände sind am boden beine sind in der
luft und ihr bewegt wieder zwischen
blattl beim auto die beiden links und
rechts zum boden achtet dabei dann
natürlich darauf dass immer der rücken
stabil ist und entsprechend die
wirbelsäule so gut wie es geht ja immer
richtung marke gedrückt wird und geht
schon aus 30 sekunden arbeitszeit
scheibenwischer jetzt auch die
einfachere variante wäre in dem fall mit
den langen hebel zu verwenden die beine
durch strecken sondern die beine um 90
grad winkel im kniegelenk dann wird die
übung definitiv um einiges einfacher und
so kann es auch wieder schön
stabilisieren
sehen sie konnten noch 321 30 sekunden
sind durch der herbert ist fleißig man
macht nur weiter die zweite minute vor
scheibenwischer mit kurzen heber wir
zeigen die nächste übung vor eine rücken
übung die bekannt ist das becken heben
das fersen sind am boden weg müssen der
luft und das variante haben wir heute
die statische variante das heißt das
becken bleibt oben
und jetzt nur das bein zur brust
gestrecktes aussetzt das ab und wechselt
auf der anderen seite in drei sekunden
sei als alle wieder mit dabei 21 los
gehts 30 sekunden arbeitszeiten geben
die zweite variante wäre in diesem fall
natürlich auch möglich dass man
entsprechend nur in der statik trainer
bleibt dass man sich das dynamische bein
weglassen oder eben auch das becken am
boden absetzung wieder hoch hebt
verschiedenste varianten möglich das ist
die was man heute machen ähnlich sagt
knie zur brust und wieder ausstrecken
und in fünf sekunden sahen wir schon
wieder durch 21 becken heben
abgeschlossen
kurz aus locker mit wir zeigen jetzt vor
eine variante bauch übung halbe
klappmesser das heißt die ganzen
gradmesser sind vielleicht noch bekannt
füße und oder zehenspitzen und armee
treffen sich ganz in der luft wir geben
die beine in die endposition und bewegen
nur den oberkörper dazu genau hier setzt
es die beine sind gestreckt und jetzt
den oberkörper so hoch wie es geht
hinauf im optimalfall mit den
fingerspitzen zu den zehenspitzen zwei
sekunden eine halbe gab messer zweite
variante wie in diese übung zu
intensives und die ist richtig
anstrengend bleibt es bei der sit up
variante hände bei den schläfen hände
vor der brust oder auch in vorhalte 30
sekunden beziehungsweise eine minute
wenn ihr damit arbeitszeit super
belastet der finne zum rhythmus beim
atmen genauso das heißt gott der bauch
übung gar nicht so einfach fünf sekunden
damals schon wieder durch und aus sei
das vorbei letzte übung im ersten
durchgang
wir haben leider 1000 bezeichnungen für
die übung und die lustigsten ausgesucht
die schulter und ok das heißt bitte in
eine gehobene liegestütz position das
heißt becken ganz nach oben
und jetzt liegestütz in dieser position
sehr stark in der schultermuskulatur
drinnen und erkennt dass ich einfacher
machen indem er mit ganz weit oben geht
es wie niki dann wird das ganze ab ist
einfacher geht's los 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit der radwechsel letzte übung
erster durchgang
konzentriert bleiben jeder geht so tief
runter wir es noch stabilisieren kann
und dass ich muskuläre dann wieder
herausdrücken kann nach fünf sekunden
321 sei es durch nicht die kurze pause
kurz aus lokal schluck trinken herbert
nach 30 sekunden oder 25 mittlerweile
nur mehr schöne arbeiten schöne
belastung schultermuskulatur und
oberarme
das sah man mit drinnen 15 sekunden
durchbeißen auch ihr zuhause
43 21 euro
beide haben sie verdient ihr zuhause
haben sich natürlich auch eine pause
verdient wir machen jetzt eine minute
serien pause lockert sich aus trinkt
einen schluck macht sich bereit
im zweiten durchgang noch mal und wie
versprochen die die jetzt der 30 30 am
anfang gemacht haben können jetzt
natürlich wechseln und keine minute
belastung machen oder 55 sekunden kurz
station wechseln und dann geht schon
wieder los ja so machen es ja jetzt
macht die nici minute durch und der
herbert geht in die variante 30 sekunden
so haben wir den wechsel schon drinnen
und in 30 sekunden statt marge wieder
das heißt langsam aber sicher bereit
machen wasserflasche versorgen erste
übung was sagt herbert christ erinnern
gerne auf vier füßen mit armen
bahnstrecken was damit fahren wir wieder
an position einnehmen noch einmal zu
wiederholen wenn das knie am boden
bleibt wird deutlich einfacher wenn das
knie abhebt vom boden jetzt richtig
richtig schwierig drei sekunden länger
los 21 und übung ab achtet darauf dass
beckham bleibt stabil und gerade gerade
wenn du die schwierige variante macht
man sie ganz ganz bewusst darauf achten
und wenn ihr merkt das gelingt man hat
ganz gut dann wächst du einfach auf die
einfachere variante
das ist genauso option dass sie dann
einfach die position während der übung
mir etwas einfacher machen ja achtet
darauf es ist schwer weiß aber dass das
knie nicht zu weit nach oben kommt wenn
sie das kloster ist genau das was unten
lassen 30 sekunden haben zwar schon
herbert 30 sekunden vorbei ausrasten
zwar anstrengend oder da merkt man
wirklich an deutlichen unterschied zu
übungs variante eins und zwei wenn das
knie an nur zwei zentimeter in der luft
ist das ist dreimal so schwer nicht die
halbzeit 15 sekunden hast noch den
fersen
die zweite position wechseln
bauchmuskulatur spannen und geht's los
innen auf die ferse klopfen mit den
händen und entsprechend entweder die
fersen hochheben und da arbeiten oder
diversen am boden lassen
ich kriege in beiden fällen eine gute
spannung gute arbeit in meiner
bauchmuskulatur hinein und falls im jahr
wiederholt atmen ganz wichtig der muskel
kehrt mit sauerstoff versorgt drei
sekunden nur 21 kurze pause herbert
dritte übung war für die schulterblätter
schulterblatt fix autoren eine variante
rückenlage album 90 grad vom körper weg
und ihr drückt so stark es geht mit den
ellbogen in den boden dass sich der
oberkörper loslöst genau und zweite
variante war in der bauchlage das
hochheben der album mit abgelegten kopf
so dass wir wirklich schön in der
schultermuskulatur drehen sind fünf
sekunden
dann geht es mit der variante
schulterblatt fixateur anschluss 21
wichtig dabei ist die variante d richter
herbert zeigt nicht den bauch
anzuspannen der muss ruhig bleiben da
muss locker bleiben weil sonst wird es
zu einer substanz wird zu einer bauch
übung und wir sagen nicht dort muskulär
wohnraum wo sehen sie konnten und er
setzt bei der zweiten variante den
ellbogen nach oben ziehen es gefunkt
zwischen hans electro statisch
aufgeladen album nach oben ziehen man
komme genau da rein 30 uhr arbeitszeiten
mittlerweile wieder vorbei
nico arbeit brav weiter und jahre alt
wird sagen die nächste übung name als
erinnerung seitlich seit stütz und
windmühle
das heißt nach oben greifen und nach
unten drehen und in 10 sekunden geht es
schon wieder los
die station wechsel in den selbstschutz
gleich direkt hinein arbeitszeit auch
für euch zu hause geht los kurze hebel
oder langer hebel je nachdem was die
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur noch hergibt
und die rotation nach oben greifen da
der hand nachschauen noch durchgreifen
unter dem körper so weit wie es geht so
dass man auch in der stabilen position
bleiben können
fünf sekunden dann haben wir die ersten
30 wieder erledigt sei das zumindest für
ein herbert bei uns für euch zu hause
die die minute durch arbeiten gut
halbzeit ist vorbei
wichtig ist das becken durch zu strecken
das aus den hintern anzuspannen dass man
das schöne spannung in der
bauchmuskulatur drin haben sehen
sekunden noch okay position wechseln die
nächste übung gleiche übung andere seite
und geht's los
keine zeit verstreichen lassen ohne
übung gespannen bewegen ganz wichtig und
darum muskel an sich die gesamte
rumpfmuskulatur die mischung aus
bauchmuskeln rückenmuskeln und alles was
dazugehört braucht sie in jeder
situation im alltag um einen kraft
transfer auch von unterer oberen
extremität und umgekehrt auch zu
schaffen
30 sekunden sind dabei nach der bauch
übung kommt die liegestütz variante
skorpion nur kurz zur erinnerung kennst
du schon mal darauf einstellen und
vorbereiten 15 sekunden
der herr wird sagt zach name das heißt
für sie ist hoch arme und provokativ
fünf sekunden doch nicht die position
wechseln 21 und los geht's
und herbert einmal die variante mit vor
wandern an orgaman schritt vor das copy
und bewegt sich vorwärts genau und
andere seite komfort zu mir genau das
wollen wir nachholen und dann passt bis
30 sekunden hat 25 sekunden 21 und kurze
pause finde ich aber sicher mal die
mattner stieg sofort zu mir nach dem
skorpion gehen wir in gebrauch über
heimliche aber ich sehe ja das war schon
richtig anstrengend ich gehe davon aus
für euch zu hause auch aber jetzt der
scheibenwischer brauchen muskulatur kann
die arme ein bisserl entlasten sehen sie
konnten noch nicht bereit machen
ausgangsposition 21 und los geht's
da auch wieder der kurze heber die etwas
abgeschwächte variante oder der lange
hebel wenn ich die beine ausstrecken
dann wird es entsprechend noch viel
schwieriger das zu stabilisieren will
teure variante die für euch am besten
ist woher die bauchmuskeln 30 sekunden
oder auch 60 sekunden voll belasten
könnte fünf sekunden dann haben wir
wieder die halbzeit erreicht für dich
niki zeit ist aus kurze pause drei
übungen bleiben uns nur eine rücken
übung das becken heben die halben gab
messer und wie man bezeichnet haben den
schulter hund und dann sahen wir durch
15 sekunden
wir beginnen mit dem becken heben
statisch das becken nach oben drücken
und das bein dazu zur brust sind fünf
sekunden nicht die position wechseln 2 1
los geht's
auch hier wie gesagt haben wir schon
ganz viele varianten von diesen becken
gegeben von dem becken in der position
gemacht wichtig ist muskulatur gesäß
arbeitet unterer rücken arbeit und
teilweise auch der die
oberschenkelrückseite da kann die
belastung richtig gut steuern
für meine rückenmuskulatur drei sekunden
21 herbert zwar über eine firma auch was
machen die scheiben gartner ist das
andere ja das heißt beine nach oben
strecken und den körper dazu aufrichten
20 sekunden haben wir noch das heißt es
jetzt sie den oberkörper dazu und das
sag mal gut mit dabei zehn sekunden
macht sich breit begibt sich in position
321 und halbe gradmesser arbeitszeit
zieht den oberkörper so gut es geht auf
und auch die zweite variante sieht ups
könnt sie waren mit den händen wie
gesagt vor der brust erkennst die hände
in vorhalte gehen dann wird es ein
bisschen einfacher vom winkel oder zu
den schläfen geben wenn wir es etwas
schwerer
so galt es perfekt posieren die
belastung der bauchmuskulatur als
gradmesser waren die fersen vom boden
hoch heben wenn ich mein oberkörper
worauf sie ist die übung ein bisschen zu
schwer
30 sekunden durch du hast es geschafft
eine übung eine übung bleibt noch der
schulter und genauso ist es das heißt
liegestütz mit bob möglichst weit oben
und da kann man glauben die matten weg
gemeint die rutschte weg oder ich habe
sowohl auf zeiten kommst doch vorher
wird
und jetzt da wo proben und der kopf
bewegt sich hinunter
in fünf sekunden nimmt die position ein
letzte übung die letzten 30 sekunden
oder die letzten 60 sekunden je nachdem
jetzt geht's los
genau da kopf bewegt sich runter und die
intensität steuert wie viel ihr nach
unten geht es wenn er ganz nach unten
geht es bis der kopf hat ansteht ist das
super super super super schwierig und
waren nur kleine bewegung macht ist
immer noch sehr sehr schwierig sehr
komplexe übung in 30 und 18 uhr das
war's 30 sekunden vorbei nickel die
letzten 30 sekunden und für euch zu
hause auch die letzten 30 sekunden
belastung an schulter und nach 20.15
durchbeißen die letzten paar
wiederholungen zehn sekunden noch alle
aufmerksamkeit nickis bei dir fünf
sekunden a321 und arme aus locker ganzen
körper mal durchschütteln
lula spannung raus lassen besser an
training ist natürlich immer wieder die
möglichkeit einen cooldown programm
einzuführen einzubauen her zum schluss
abbau minuten zeit nehmen
wir nehmen uns jetzt alle übungen noch
heraus am besten nachdem die arme jetzt
so belastet worden hätte gesagt was
einfach einmal ausschütteln aus lockern
genau entsprechend bislang lockere
bewegung drin zu haben vor dem körper
hin und her schwingen
wir kennen auch sie mir was zum
aufwärmen gemacht dann aus davor
halteposition
die hände hin und her schwingen lassen
oder wie es bei den schwimmern war was
man schon gelernt haben in der position
mit links und rechts zusammenklappen zu
den schultern greifen
ihr habt es ganz ganz viele übungen auch
im kudamm prozess bereits von uns
bekommen macht zwei minuten hinten drauf
gibt dem körper die möglichkeit auch
etwas zu regenerieren
ich habe gesagt danke cool gemacht dort
trainiert niki du genauso
ja wir haben ein intensives
krafttraining mit euch abgeschlossen wir
haben heute ist und uns voll belastet
was die rumpfmuskulatur die
bauchmuskulatur die rückenmuskulatur
betrifft für heute war es dass wir
freuen uns auf morgen wie es am morgen
für euch wieder da brauchst einen
schönen tag und man kann ja mal wieder
gemeinsam weiter